[Musik]
eine gemeinde im oberbayerischen
landkreis eichstätt in der nähe von
ingolstadt knapp achteinhalb 1000
einwohner leben hier
jeder kennt jeden
wir treffen bezirksrätin stephanie
kirchner
die 45 jährige ist mitglied der partei
die linke und arbeitet als
krankenschwester
anfang juli wurde sie abends auf dem weg
nach hause überfallen
linksseitig plötzlich einen stich im
unterbauch und kaum habe ich das
registriert wurde ich bereits mit
irgendeinem seil band stranguliert und
richtig massiv ist mir heute immer noch
einen kopf der satz im kreis linke
stephanie kirchner zeigt uns fotos von
ihren verletzungen am ganzen körper
der angriff war massiv
ja das sieht nun die stichverletzung die
linken unterbauch und wo ich auch von
glück reden sagen muss das sind nicht so
in die tiefe gegangen ist das
irgendeinen organ mit verletzt worden
erst mal wie sehr schwingt die angst mit
die angst ist immer im nacken dabei und
ich hab mich auch zu fuß unterwegs wenn
ich hinter mir was wäre ich drehe mich
um also die angst ist immer präsent ich
habe ja schon den eindruck gehabt es mit
durch den ausspruch ihr scheiß linke
dass es sich schon auf mich als
mandatsträgerin halt auch bezogen hat
staatsschutz und staatsanwaltschaft
ermitteln
der tatort ein kleiner grünstreifen
neben der hauptstraße hierhin traut
kirchner sich noch nicht fühlen sie sich
von der polizei und justiz genügend
unterstützt aktuell so nicht dass ich
hier in kösching unterstützt wird
geschützt wird gar nicht ich finde es
schon traurig dass die mittel nicht nasa
nach seiner tat einen betroffenen
mögliche schutzmaßnahmen noch intensiver
anbieten zu können
es gibt 300.000 kommunalpolitiker in
deutschland bei veranstaltungen bekommt
stephanie kirchner nun auf wunsch
besonderen schutz
aber nicht rund um die uhr
[Musik]
wut und hass gegen kommunalpolitiker
auch der düsseldorfer oberbürgermeister
thomas geisel erfährt dass es ist
kommunal wahlkampf in nordrhein
westfalen bei manchen ist der frust groß
geisel bekommt den unmut mit und er
bekommt drogen
sie haben als oberbürgermeister
anfeindungen erlebt beispielsweise als
sie sich für die seenotrettung stark
gemacht haben wie war das
auf der einen seite gab es also mails
die wirklich bedrohungen ausgesprochen
haben auch gegenüber meiner familie so
nach dem motto wir wissen wo du bist und
was mich auch sehr betroffen gemacht hat
dass viele mails und wirklich blanken
rassismus enthalten haben und das häufig
mit echter adresse und ich muss sagen
das halte ich doch wieso wir sagen einen
tabubruch firma so will das gab es vor
zehn jahren glaube ich nicht die droh
mails reißen nicht ab
zuerst ging es oft und
flüchtlingspolitik inzwischen ist auch
corona regelmäßig anlass
sehr geehrter geislingen spinnen sie so
langsam oder ist ihnen das corona virus
in ihrem dummen kopf gestiegen sie dumme
stück scheiße ich hoffe ihnen prügel
dass jemand aus ihrem unterbelichteten
hirn sie dummschwätzer merken sie sich
das ansonsten wünsche ich ihnen dass sie
diese spitz ag die heute ein dach eines
autos durchschlagen hat ihren hohlen
kopf durchbohrt und die halbe stadt
pinkelt auf ihr krad
thomas geisel hat familie vier
schulpflichtige kinder seine frau vera
begleitet ihn manchmal auf öffentlichen
terminen
die bedrohung trifft ganze familien und
nicht alle halten durch 2009 10 gab es
1674 politisch motivierte straftaten
gegen amts und mandatsträger 2018 waren
es noch 1200 56 fälle die tatmotive 609
fälle waren rechts motiviert 310 links
motiviert 727 nicht zuzuordnen
davor wurden die zahlen für abends und
mandatsträger überhaupt nicht
systematisch erhoben die behörden
erkannten aber die steigende tendenz im
herbst 2015 attackiert ein mann aus
fremdenfeindlichen motiven die kölner
politikerin henriette reker mit einem
messer sie überlebt schwer verletzt
am zweiten juni 2009 10 wird der
kasseler regierungspräsident walter
lübcke vor seinem wohnhaus mit einem
pistolenschuss aus nächster nähe in den
kopf getötet
dringend tatverdächtig ein
rechtsextremist als tatmotiv nannte er
äußerungen lüpkes während der
flüchtlingskrise 2015
der cdu mann hatte sich damals für die
aufnahme von flüchtlingen ausgesprochen
[Musik]
der mordfall lübker hat viele noch
nachdenklicher gemacht und focke aus
einem kleinen ort in niedersachsen hat
aufgegeben er erhielt drohungen per mail
und per anruf das war nicht alles
das war damals so das ist leider treiben
gab die bei mir im briefkasten gelandet
sind wo darauf stand wir vergessen dich
wie die antifa oder eben auch jedoch zu
den ziegen füttern punkt wo sie sich
gesagt haben ich wenn ich habe ja der
punkt war ganz klar erkennbar schreiben
oder den drohschreiben die einfach an
zwei verschiedenen tagen in meinem
kasten waren und dann natürlich der
tatsache dass auf dem grundstück leute
herumkaspern die der meinung sind sie
müssten dann hakenkreuze auf mein auto
schmieren da habe ich dann für mich die
grenze gezogen dass zumindest das thema
kommunalpolitische ämter ebenso nicht
mehr geht
[Musik]
vockel ist als bürgermeister
zurückgetreten die entscheidung findet
er noch immer richtig
der hass aus dem netz wird immer öfter
real
wir treffen den konfliktforscher andreas
zick er beobachtet ein klima der form
auch in der mitte der gesellschaft
der hass habe sich bann gebrochen
wenn man die entwicklung des hasses
sieht woher kommt der jetzt
er kommt aus rechtspopulistischen
bewegung er kommt aus rechtsextremen
bewegung im moment sind wir in corona
zeiten der kommt aus verschwörungs
gruppen er kommt aus den großen
netzwerken der hass wird dort geschürt
der hass ist eine emotion die identität
schafft und auf einem feindbild basiert
nun sind davon auch kommunalpolitiker in
sehr kleinen gemeinden betroffen also
leute die gar nicht so fern sind die ich
kenne persönlich wie weit lässt sich das
in übereinstimmung bringen in dem moment
wo sie dann greifen agieren sie nicht
mehr gegenüber einer person die sie
kennen sondern sie agieren gegen einen
politiker der das system repräsentiert
seit juni gibt es das neue gesetz zur
bekämpfung des rechtsextremismus und der
hasskriminalität es soll einen stärkeren
strafrechtlichen schutz von
kommunalpolitikern bewirken auch üble
nachrede ist jetzt strafbar
kommunalpolitiker können auch
auskunftssperren für ihre daten im
melderegister erwirken und soziale
netzwerke müssen die ip-adressen
verdächtiger personen melden
in berlin treffen wir frank christian
hansen er ist parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer der fdp fraktion im
berliner abgeordnetenhaus
hansel wohnt hier in berlin schöneberg
vor seinem haus ging sein auto in
flammen auf brandstiftung der
staatsschutz ermittelt
der brennende wagen vom haus mitten in
der nacht für hansel ein schock
das ist geboren ich freue mich wenn man
auch weiter denkt und das gefühl haben
müsste es könnte ja auch tatsächlich mal
die person selbst treffen
also vom körper her nach diesem vorfall
ich schaue ich mich schon ein bisschen
anders und wenn ich normal in der straße
laufe der guckt einen an
wie reagieren die leute
das ausgebrannte auto ist nicht die
erste bedrohung vor einem jahr entlud
sich die wut vor frank christian hansens
wohnung
82 leute da haben wir da krawall gemacht
relativ laut nach bhutan zu der nazi das
geht hier nicht in unserem kiez und auf
dem weg und darüber ob man sich das
schon gedanken die afd werde als
abstraktes feindbild wahrgenommen sagt
hansel nicht als bürgerliche partei als
die er sie sehe
es gibt ja nun auch das argument dass
die afg genau das klima des hasses
befördert dass sie beklagen beteiligter
personen aus oder sollten es nicht tun
sondern wir sagen wir melden die
politischen fehlentwicklungen an
sichtbar ist auf vielen seiten der afd
geht es weniger bürgerlich zu
das sind leute sie sich auskotzen und
das ist auch aus meiner sicht ein ganz
großes demokratisches moment dass wir
dieses bei uns leider die leute noch
glauben bei uns können sie sich aus
kurzen sonst gibt es gar nicht
[Musik]
was auskotzen auch noch bedeuten kann
hat kassim apache zu spüren bekommen
rabatt schießt abgeordneter der spd
in der hamburgischen bürgerschaft er
ruft im hamburger wahlkampf migranten
zur wahl auf um rechtsextremen am end zu
halten
eine regelrechte wutwelle trifft den
55-jährigen sie wollen also mit hilfe
von hamburgs menschen abfall die wahl
gewinnen und die ft rausschmeißen sie
sollten nicht vergessen dass sie nur
eine minderwertige kleiner esel kicker
sind sie haben in unserem land keine
rechte schon die nahe zukunft werden sie
es zusammen mit dem anderen [ __ ]
dreck in die lager wandern mit deutschen
größer
inwieweit schüchtern sie diese hats mir
jetzt ein ja ist er unser kennt mich und
macht mich auch nachdenklich weil es
sich nicht nur mal ein zufall handelt
sondern es handelt sich um mehrere mails
und das ist ein beispiel dafür
das macht mir angst weil perücken und
entschulden idioten gibt es überall aber
das sind diese intensität in dieser
anzahl ins solchen hass mails kommt das
macht mir
die flut von mails sei organisiert sagt
abazi das ist schon systematisch das ist
nicht nur in den sozialen medien was wir
diesen hass mails und diese hetze haben
wir erleben auf der straße immer wieder
ich das nicht zum ersten mal dass sich
auch körperlich angegriffen worden bin
ich habe damals gar nicht darüber viel
nachgedacht wo ich gesagt habe auch das
kann auch passieren aber nach dieser
hass mails das hat mich noch mal
nachdenklich gemacht
[Musik]
sich gegen hass zu wehren ist immer noch
nicht leicht erst recht nicht digital
staatsanwaltschaft köln seit drei jahren
arbeitet hier das deutschlandweit erste
sonderdezernat für hassrede im netz sie
versuchen die urheber von hass post zu
ermitteln sie vor gericht zu bringen
wo sind wir nur angelernt wenn die
[ __ ] jetzt auch noch höhere
politische ämter bekleiden dürfen
verlogenes aufgedunsen des hirnloses
weil zurzeit sind wir am planen wie und
wann wir sie hinrichten werden auf
welche konkreten schwierigkeiten stoßen
sie denn bei der juristischen verfolgung
des hasses wir müssen uns das posting
anschauen wir müssen uns den kontext
anschauen und wir müssen eben strenger
überprüfen ist hier meinung oder liegt
ja in eine meinung vor die
möglicherweise drastisch ist aber eben
noch kein straftatbestand erfüllt und
wenn es das nicht tut steht es uns nicht
zu hier ein ermittlungsverfahren
einzuleiten
hinzu kommt die arbeit dieser
staatsanwaltschaft bist noch neuland die
justiz lebt größtenteils noch in der
analogen welt ganz plastisch formuliert
werden dauerhaft nicht erfolgreich sein
wenn wir twitter verläufe ausdrucken
knicken lochen abheften und din a4
aktendeckel heften wir brauchen einen
umfassenden umfassenderen ansatz wir
brauchen einen digitalen ansatz und da
ist sicherlich noch
optimierungspotenzial
wie sehr der hass inzwischen
kommunalpolitiker betrifft zeigt eine
aktuelle umfrage der zeitschrift
kommunal wurden im vergangenen jahr noch
41 prozent der bürgermeister nach
eigenen angaben beleidigt beschimpft
bedroht oder tätlich angegriffen
so sind es 2020 fast zwei drittel
sehr viele politikerinnen werden eben
beleidigt diffamiert dass es werden
falsche informationen über sie
verbreitet und wenn sie das anzeigen bei
der polizei und bei der
staatsanwaltschaft wird das oftmals
eingestellt weil man eben sagt und das
ist nicht von öffentlichem interesse
sondern da müssen sie ihn privat gegen
vorgehen und da unterstützen wir eben
bei zivilrechtlichen prozessen
[Musik]
torsten hat seine eigene strategie mit
den anfeindungen umzugehen
er ist oberbürgermeister in einer
kleinstadt in ostsachsen wird im netz
angefeindet bei seinem privatwagen
wurden die radmuttern los geschraubt nur
durch glück ist ihm nichts passiert der
49-jährige lädt regelmäßig zur
oberbürgermeister gerüchteküche
mitten auf dem marktplatz mit leuten
reden auch mal zum blitzableiter sein
für mich persönlich sehr wichtig um
einfach ein stimmungsbild zu erfahren
von den menschen die hier leben sind
aber auch ein bisschen sozusagen ventil
zu sein
viele leute und da geht es vielfach noch
mal um große politik das wort sozusagen
globalisiert und ein schuldiger gesucht
der für dinge zuständig ist und in den
kommunen ist es nun mal
die bürgermeisterin der bürgermeister
also diskussionsbedarf gibt es jede
menge die stadt in der oberlausitz
steckt mitten im strukturwandel die
angestellten im rat als alle die bis
zehnmal mehr bewegen und die parteien
seit zehn jahren ist patch an der
stadtspitze
er sucht weiter ständig das gespräch
trotz aller anfeindungen ich glaube
jetzt ist die möglichkeit um an die
menschen heranzukommen sich die dinge
auch zu stellen auch persönlich zu
stellen
doch mal zu sagen okay stimmt haben sie
recht ist schlecht gelaufen
es wird nicht immer gelingen aber teil
der frustration und ein teil das der
aggression kann man für meinen dafür
halten dort definitiv
haben sie auch schon mal morgen ist
gefühl gab bei der gerüchteküche auch
schon mal angst gehabt wenn ich manche
leute sehe wo ich weiß dass die
integrativ sind deswegen halte ich dann
immer auch gut den abstand und jetzt
durch das ist ganz gut dass sozusagen
zwei stehtische dort sind man weiß immer
bei manchen nicht eben was passieren
wird und den ein oder anderen euro zu
dass dort mal vielleicht auch ein
gegenstand gezogen wird
krisen fördern den hass auch der
konfliktforscher andreas zick zeichnet
ein pessimistisches bild das wir werden
das noch weniger über gewalt und
aggression von einzelnen teilen sondern
wir werden in verteilungskonflikte in
der gesellschaft hinein laufen wir
wissen dass aus schweren ökonomischen
krisen wir wissen dass aus
naturkatastrophen im auslauf von solchen
krisen nehmen die innere
gesellschaftlichen konflikte zu
und das kommt der hats wieder hinein das
heißt die feindbilder nehmen auch zu
düstere aussichten
unterwegs in dortmund-dorstfeld der
stadtteil gilt als hochburg der extremen
und gewaltbereiten rechten szene
in dieser stadt tritt andreas hollstein
von der cdu als bürgermeisterkandidat an
einer der weitermacht bislang war er
bürgermeister in der beschaulichen
kleinstadt altena im sauerland 2017
wurde mit einem messer angegriffen weil
er in altena besonders viele flüchtlinge
aufgenommen hatte
sie haben nach der messerattacke weitere
morddrohungen erhalten warum machen sie
weiter warum tun sie sich das an
ja weil ich glaube dass politik mut und
haltung auch und dass ich irgendwann mal
in die politik gegangen den unter genau
den vorsitzen das vorleben zu wollen
glaube da muss man klar flagge zeigen
muss dass verteidigen was wir in
deutschland haben unsere demokratie egal
in welcher partei man ist wahlkampf in
zeiten von corona eine schwierige sache
es gibt viel gesprächsbedarf bei dem
thema wahlkampf an der haustür immer
wieder begegnet andreas hollstein
menschen die mit den entscheidungen der
politik nicht einverstanden sind sich
distanzieren
er erlebt auch die ablehnung von politik
ganz generell
es sind polarisierende zeiten
sind dass diejenigen die so viel frust
gegen das system haben dass sie sagen
ich will mit politik nichts mehr zu tun
haben
ja ich glaube ich würde schon etwas
bösartiger machen ich glaube dass gerade
die rechte seite so ganz
gezielt an das thema flüchtlinge daran
gegangen ist und jetzt ganz gezielt an
das thema corona dran geht um den
spaltpilz in unserer gesellschaft
anzusetzen und da dürfen wir nicht
mitmachen wir müssen den aus gegenteil
tun wir müssen wieder zusammenführen
als politik es ist ein wahlkampf in dem
politiker besonderen schutz benötigen
keiner wird angegriffen von den kollegen
und kolleginnen war sie die personen
sind behaupte ich mal sondern weil sie
für den start gehen
ich erwarte von der gesellschaft
eigentlich die rückendeckung dass man
aufhört auf politik einzudreschen ohne
zu verstehen was da gemacht wird ich
verstehe viele kritik an der politik
und da gibt es auch viel berechtigte
kritik aber man muss miteinander im
dialog bleiben nicht immer erlaubt die
stimmung dialog
[Applaus]
das miteinander ist bedroht und das
engagement der menschen in den kommunen
der hass hat in den vergangenen jahren
zugenommen aber der kampf dagegen hat
jetzt zumindest begonnen denn der hass
gefährdet die demokratie und die
gesellschaft in der wir leben
[Musik]